[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
مدير وكاله الطاقه الذريه يؤكد ان ايران
وافقت على استئناف اجراءات المراقبه في
المنشاه النوويه
في اول تدريب من نوعه السعوديه وامريكا
تجريان مناورات مشتركه نهايه مارس لمواجهه
هجمات مسيرات
بعد تكهنات بتعرض البحر الاحمر لخطر
الزلزال خبراء جيولوجيون يؤكدون ان دول
الخليج بعيده عن الهزات
في الرابع كذلك
السعوديه تطلق اول مدرسه لصناع الفكر
ومبادره اخرى لتطوير مؤسسات المجتمع
المدني في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
في اول نسخ مسابقه المهارات الثقافيه
السعوديه اكثر من 240 الف مشاركه من
المدارس يخوضون مشاركه من المدارس يخضون
رحله من سبع محطات
حياكم الله اكد مدير الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافاييل كروسي ان ايران
وافقت على استئناف اجراءات المراقبه
والتحقق الاضافيه في المواقع النوويه بعد
عامين من توقفها واضاف غروسيا ان ايران
نفذت تغييرا كبيرا في التصاميم المعلنه
لمحطه فوردو دون ابلاغ الوكاله مسبقا
بالمخالفه الالتزاماتها بموجب اتفاقيه
الضمانات الخاصه بهم ولفت ايضا الى ان
مفتشي الوكاله رصدوا في منشاه فوردو
جزيئات من اليورانيوم عالي التقسيط
بمستويات اعلى بكثير من المعلن واعرب
جروسي عن تطلعه لبدء المتابعات الفنيه في
ايران والتعاون الفوري والكامل مع مفكر
شيء الوكاله بما في ذلك المواقع الثلاثه
غير المعلنه التي وجدت الوكاله فيها اثارا
لجزيئات اليورانيوم
يجب ان نتعلم من خبراتنا السابقه ومما
تعلمته في خارطه الطريق والمواعيد
والتواريخ يمكن ان لا تستجيب للواقع الذي
نواجهه نركز في الوقت الحالي على حل
المشاكل العالقه امامنا وبالطبع نتعامل مع
خلفيه قائمه على وقائع سياسيه وندرك انها
لا يمكن ان تستمر كذلك اود ان نحلها بحلول
الاسبوع المقبل لكن بالطبع ستستغرق وقتا
دعا رئيس لجنه العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس
الشيوخ الامريكي السيناتور بوب من انديز
الامم المتحده الى التحقيق في شبكه مراكز
التعذيب السريه التي استخدمها النظام
الايراني كاداه لسحق وقمع الاحتجاجات
وكانت شبكه سي ان ان نشرت في فبراير
الماضي تحقيقا عن مراكز التعذيب السريه
التي يستخدمها النظام الايراني لمعامله
المتظاهرين بوحشيه ولاجبارهم على الخضوع
وكشفت الشبكه ان العديد من تلك المعتقلات
تعمل داخل منشات حكوميه او تابعه للحرس
الثوري الايراني بصفه سريه غير معلنه
قال مسؤولون غربيون لصحيفه
متردده في شراء صواريخ باليستيه من ايران
خشيه اقدام حلفاء اوكرانيا على تزويد كييف
بصواريخ بعيده المدى واكد المسؤولون
للصحيفه البريطانيه ان موسكو قد تغير
موقفها بسبب النقص في حجم ذخائرها الموجهه
بدقه فضلا عن تعثر انتاجها المحلي كما
نقلت الصحيفه عن سفيره واشنطن جوليان سميث
ان الغربيين يجدون العلاقه الروسيه
الايرانيه مقلقه للغايه وان الحلفاء
سيواصل ارسال اشارات لايران حول مخاطر
دعمها لروسيا في الحرب مع اوكرانيا
على وقع تصاعد المعارك في باخم تحضر رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر الروسيه من انهيار خط مواجهه
اذا اجبرت فاجنر او اجبرت فاجنر على
الانسحاب من المدينه
اذا انسحبت شركه فان الجبهه ستنهار
باكملها فاجنر متراصه ويمكنها سحب الجيش
الاوكراني وتدميره مع عدم السماح لهم
بالتركيز على اجزاء اخرى من خط المواجهه
ايضا نحن نتقدم الى الامام ويجب على
الاخرين اتباعنا باي طريقه لحفظ ماء الوجه
ما يعني اعاده التعلم ويمكننا القيام بذلك
من المهم كسر الصوره النمطيه المقاتلون
يسالونني لماذا التاخير في امدادات
الذخيره التي تعهدت بها وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه يجب شرح ذلك في موسكو وايضا لماذا
لا يسمحون لنا بتجنيد عناصر جدد
من جانبه قال الرئيس الاوكراني انه اتفق
مع القاده العسكريين على استمرار عمليات
الدفاع عن باخموت وخلال اجتماع مع كبار
قاده العسكريين بحث
توزيع الاسلحه والمعدات بحسب العمليات على
الجبهات
ذكرت وسائل الاعلام من اسرائيليه ان وزير
الامن القومي اتمار بن جفير امر الشرطه
بتنفيذ عمليات هدم لوحدات سكنيه
للفلسطينيين وصفها بغير القانونيه تقع في
القدس الشرقيه خلال شهر رمضان وياتي تحرك
بنكفير على الرغم من اتخاذ قرار بحسب
القانون الاسرائيلي بمنع هدم الابنيه غير
القانونيه في القدس الشرقيه خلال شهر
رمضان لمنع اثاره التوتر في المقابل ادانا
الخارجيه الفلسطينيه تصريحات
مشيره الى انها تحرض على المزيد من
التصعيد
صرح المتحدث باسم حزب الجيد التركي
المعارض في تركيا كورشاد زورلو ان الحزب
قدم مقترحا جديدا بان يصبح رئيس بلديه
اسطنبول منصوريه ورئيس بلديه انقره اكرم
امام اوغلو نائبين لرئيس الجمهوريه يذكر
ان رؤساء بلديات اكبر محافظتين تركيتين
ينتميان الى حزب الشعب الجمهوري والذي يعد
اكبر حزب معارض في تركيا
اعلنا موقع مونيتر الامريكي ان الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه تخططان لبدء اول تدريب
تجريبي على الاطلاق لمكافحه الطائرات بدون
طيار في الاسبوع الاخير من شهر مارس
الجاري الموقع نقل ايضا عن اربع مصادر
عسكريه ان مناورات الرمال الحمراء
المشتركه بين الرياض واشنطن ستشمل انظمه
دفاع جوي مملوكه للولايات المتحده
والسعوديه كما ستضم في وقت لاحق مشاركه
جيوش اقليميه من الشرق الاوسط وسيقدم
الجيش الامريكي للسعوديه جهاز محاكاه
كمبيوتر جديد جرى تطويره العمل الماضي
لتدريب الافراد على الرد على هجمات
المسيرات المعاديه بحسب المصادر
من واشنطن يلتحق بنا ريتشارد وايتس مدير
برنامج التحليل السياسيه العسكري في معهد
اديسون سيد ريتشارد مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض برايك اولا ما الاهميه
العسكريه التي يكتسبها هذا النوع من
التمارين لانه اول نوع جديد نتحدث عن
مكافحه الطائرات
المسيره الاهميه بالنسبه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه بالنسبه لامن المنطقه ايضا
من اهم التحديات التي تواجه الشرق الاوسط
هي
استخدامي المسيرات كاس اسلوب جديد من
استخدامات العسكريه شاهدنا الولايات
المتحده استخدمتها في العراق وافغانستان
واسرائيل في لبنان والان
نشهد دول اخرى تحصل عليها وتستخدمها
وبالتحديد
شهدنا
استخدام ايران او سواء بشكل مباشر او عبر
وكلائهم من الحوثيين او حزب الله
يستخدمونها لمهاجمه الاهداف عبر الشرق
الاوسط
ان التحدي اسقاط المسيرات
يكون بانها اولا رخيصه رخيصه الثمن وتناور
بشكل جيد وبامكانها تتجنب ان الدفاعات بكل
سرعه من دوري اصداريه الصوت الذي يصدره
الصاروخ فعلينا تطوير زبل افضل لهزيمتها
وهذه التمارين مصممه
للولايات المتحده ودول الخليج وكيفيه
القيام بذلك هي اسقاطها والدفاع عن اجواء
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وربما لاحقا
لتشمل دول الخليج العربي الاخرى
اليوم ما هي الانظمه التقنيات العسكريه
ايضا كذلك المتقدمه فيما يخص طائرات
التعامل مع الطائرات الدروس القادره على
التشويش على هذه الطائرات ربما ايضا
التحكم في هذه الطائرات او حتى اسقاط هذه
الطائرات نتحدث عن رخيصه الثمن وليست
المتقدمه اللي هي الصغيره التي كانت
تستخدم في وقت
سابق من قبل
الميليشيات المواليه لايران في المنطقه
كما ذكرت هنالك السبل عديده لهزيمه
المسيرات ان كان اسقاطها على الارض قبل
اقلاعها وامكاننا
التشويش على
الملاحه من خلال مثلا التزويدها
بالمعلومات السيبرانيه الخاطئه او حتى
عرقله
قدرتها على الاستهداف من خلال تمويه
الاهداف وحتى اتدخل
بالاتصالات بين المسيره وبين المشغل او
حتى بامكانها اسقاطها كل هذه الاساليب
استخدمت بنجاح من قبل الاوكرانيين ضد
المسيرات الايرانيه هناك
التحدي بلا شك هو
انس
بعضها السبل قد تكون معاقده او مكلفه لذلك
سيبحثون عن السبل الاكثر وفعاليه لعرقلتها
عبر هذه التمارين او المناورات الحاليه
وقد تشمل حسب استخدام الليزر او اسلحه
الطاقه الموجهه التي نواجهها ضد المسيره
لتف من اسقاطها باستخدام الصاروخ او شيء
مكلف بهذا التمرين سيقدم فيه الجيش
الامريكي جهاز محاكاه
لكمبيوتر طبعا طورته الولايات المتحده
العام الماضي للتعامل مع المسيرات اسال
هنا الى اين وصلت الولايات المتحده فعلا
في تطوير اجهزه
قادره على ان تتصدى لهذه الطائرات المسيره
في تطوير اجهزه ايضا قادره على التشويش
ومساعده الدول التي قد تواجه خطر الطائرات
المسيره
المتحده
منحت هذه المساله الاولويه شاهدنا بان
الايرانيين او حتى وكلاهم في العراق
هاجموا القواعد الامريكيه في العراق وكذلك
في سوريا في مساله الدفاع عن النفس والان
بعدما حصل في اوكرانيا فاصبحت اولويه ذا
تقصها هناك وكذلك الهجمات الايرانيه على
على
مجمعات الاتيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
فبلا شك هذه هي اولويه ولايات متحده حققت
تقدما
لفهمي
الفارقه بين الدفاع ضد الطائرات والصواريخ
البالستيه مقارنه بصواريخ الكروز
والمسيارات
التحدي الان هو لجعلها اكثر فاعليه فبدلا
من اسقاطها او عرقله نصف المسيرات فنريد
ان نفعل ذلك
مع تسعه وتسعين بالمئه منها وجهاز
المحاكاه سيساعدنا على تجربه الاساليب
المختلفه وبكل سرعه مثلا
تجربه برنامج
وتعرف اذا ما نجح او تغيير الخوارزميات
ينجح بمشاكل الافضل فهذا سيسهل ويسرع
العمليه باستخدام الاساليب المختلفه بدلا
من اسقاطها
بالصواريخ مثلا حقيقيه وهذا ربما سياتي
لاحقا اشكرك جزيل الشكر من واشنطن ريتشارد
وايت مدير برنامج التحليل السياسي العسكري
في معهد شكرا جزيلا لك
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
في يومه الثاني المؤتمر العدلي الدولي
يناقش توظيف الذكاء الاصطناعي ودوره في
تحسين العداله
حياكم الله من جديد في الرياض اقتتموا
اليوم اعمال المؤتمر العدلي الدولي الذي
نظمته وزاره العدل السعوديه بهدف تعزيز
التقنيات المسانده للعمل القضائي في
العالم وشاهد المؤتمر على مدى يومين
مشاركه وزراء وقاده القطاع العدلي من 50
دوله وبحث في يومه الثاني توظيف الذكاء
الاصطناعي في القطاع العدلي
خطط جديده لتعزيز استخدام التقنيه في
الانظمه العدليه العالميه تقودها السعوديه
بتنظيمها للمؤتمر العدلي الدولي في نسخته
الاولى بالرياض لبناء الشركات العدليه
ونقل التجارب بين الدول جلسه مستقبل
القضاء التي شارك فيها وزير العدل السعودي
مع نظرائه من دول عربيه واجنبيه اكدت على
ان التحول الرقمي في القطاع لن يغني
العالم عن القاضي الانسان لكنها ستقصر من
مدد التقاضي وتسرع اجراءاته لا شك اننا
نامل ان يكون بعد هذا المؤتمر تواصل كبير
بين العديد من وزارات العدل على مستوى
العالم في معرفه اثار التحولات الرقميه
والضمانات القضائيه وترسيخ قواعد العداله
من خلال التفاهم وتبادل الخبرات والاثراء
المعرفي بين مختلف الدول
تنظيم المؤتمر الاول من نوعه في المنطقه
انعكست نتائجه على القطاع العدلي بالمملكه
فقد رخصت وزاره العدل السعوديه لاول ثلاثه
مكاتب محاماه من بريطانيا وامريكا لممارسه
الانشطه القانونيه في البلاد مع توقعات
باثمته
75% من خدمات المحاماه في العالم خلال
السنوات العشر المقبله وفق ما اشارت اليه
توقعات الخبراء القانونيين المشاركين في
المؤتمر المشاريع التي المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اللي في صدد انها تقودها تطلب
الكفاءات والخبرات العالميه وهذا اول هدف
من الوزاره ان افتتاح مجال المهني
القانوني بحيث توطين الخبرات العالميه
وتدريب وتاهيل المحامين السعوديين لاكتساب
هذه الخبرات التشريعات العدليه الجديده في
المملكه والتقدم الملحوظ في تقنياتها ج
ذبت للمؤتمر اربعه الاف مشارك من 50 دوله
بينهم وزراء وقاده للقطاع العدلي من دول
عربيه واجنبيه ووكالات قضائيه من الرياض
نواف عزيز العربيه
[موسيقى]
انتشرت في الاونه الاخيره توقعاته لعلماء
ومتخصصين في الزلازل بحدوثها ذات ارضيه في
بعض دول الشرق الاوسط وتحديدا منطقه
الخليج تبقى تلك التوقعات في نظر البعض
مجرد تكهنات لا يمكن حدودها في ظل الكثير
من الدراسات والابحاث التي تجري في علم
الزلازل سعود الخلف مع التفاصيل
رغم تنوع الدراسات التي تجريها المراكز
البحثيه بشان الكوارث الطبيعيه التي
تشهدها الكره الارضيه لا تزال الزلازل
هاجسا مؤرقا للعديد من الدول في العالم
الامر الذي دعا متخصصين في المنطقه
العربيه الى اجراء المزيد من البحوث
والدراسات ليس من المعقول ان تكون هناك
جهات او قوه لتحريك هذه
البلاطه او تسبب في الزلازل انما هي قد
يكون هناك اجتهادات علميه لكن في الواقع
كجيولوجيا كدراسه الزلازل وبراكين لا يمكن
لاحد ان يتحكم فيه حركه صخور
لالاف الكيلومترات
وبساماكه عشرات الالاف من امتار ان تحركها
اي قوه كانت الا قوه الله سبحانه وتعالى
منطقه البحر الاحمر كانت نقطه الاختلاف
الذي دار بين المتخصصين منذ كارثه الزلازل
التي ضربت مناطق في تركيا وسوريا خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه حيث ذهب البعض الى ان
البحر الاحمر معرض لخطر الزلازل التي قد
تضرب بعض المدن المجاوره بحر احمر في
زلازل لكن تاثير علينا محدود لكن نتيجه
لشده الحراره
الموجوده في قاع وسط قاع البحر
فانها تعمل على اضمحلال الموجات الصادره
من الزلازل في وسط البحر الاحمر المدن
السعوديه على الرغم من تسجيل هزات ارضيه
محدوده خلال العقود الماضيه الا ان مراكز
الابحاث والتاريخ الزلزالي تؤكد بعد دول
الخليج عن انشطه الزلازل نحمد الله انا
لدي نا مساحه جيولوجيه وان هناك محطات
كثيره للرسل الزلزالي تتم متابعه جميع
الهزات مهما كانت صغيره لا يشعر بها
الانسان الى الزلازل الكبيره وبالتالي
تنتشر المحطات
والرصد الزلزالي موجود ونحن باذن الله
جزيره العرب بشكل عام والمملكه بشكل خاص
تقع ضمن الجزء المستقر من البلاط العربيه
يرى متخصصون ضروره التجديد خلال الفتره
المقبله على تطبيق المعايير المضاده
للزلازل في المباني وتصميمها بمواصفات
متوافقه وامنه من الهزات الارضيه اضافه
الى نشر الثقافه العامه بين الشعوب من جده
سعود الخلف العربيه
من جده ينضم الينا رئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه
للزلازل ومدير مركز الازمات والكوارث هيئه
المساحه الجيولوجيه السعوديه الدكتور هاني
زهران دكتور هاني حياك الله معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض
هل البحر الاحمر فعلا معرض لخطر الزلزال
في البدايه اشكر قناه العربيه على استضافه
حياه الى اللقاء
وبالنسبه للبحر الاحمر حقيقه الاغلب
الزلازل اللي بتقع في البحر الاحمر هي
زلازل ضعيفه الى متوسطه يعني
حتى الزلازل اللي سايره في خلال الخمسين
سنه من الستينات الى الان على سبيل المثال
الزلزال اللي اتكلم فيه البعض انه عام 67
بالقرب من
جنوب غرب جده هذا زلزال كان قوته 5.7 وليس
قوه فوق السته يعني كل الزلازل اللي بتكون
في البحر الاحمر هي
زلازل من ضعيفه الى متوسط ايش السبب خلينا
نتكلم اول حاجه عن حدود الصفيحه العربيه
وهذه اللي توضح الامور بشكل جيد
الصفيحه العربيه واللي هي تضم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
وايضا
في اليمن دول الخليج وفي الشمال ايضا
العراق وسوريا والاردن الصفيحه العربيه
يحدها من الغرب البحر الاحمر وهذا طبعا
البحر الاحمر هو صدع انفتاح لكن هذه
الصفيحه يا دكتور
هذه الصفيحه يعني جزء منها تعرض
للزلزال الزلزال الاخير الزلزال تركيا
وسوريا هو جزء من الصفيحه العربيه ايضا
تاثر في في شمال غرب سوريا فالسؤال الان
هل يمكن ان يكون مثلا هناك
تداعيات او صدع معين حدث في هذه الصفيحه
او خلل ايضا حدث ممكن ان يؤثر على مناطق
ومساحه جغرافيه اوسع او ابعد من هذه
النقطه في ذات الصفيحه العربيه التي نقع
عليها ومن ضمنها البحر الاحمر
بالتاكيد لا لانه الزلازل داخل المملكه ما
في صدوع رئيسيه تكتونيه تمر داخل الصفيحه
العربيه
واغلب الزلازل اللي بتقع في الصفيحه
العربيه بتقع على حدود الصفيحه العربيه
يعني على سبيل المثال الجزء اللي هو
الشمالي الغربي من الصفيحه العربيه
وبنتكلم عن خليج العقبه وامتداده اللي هو
صدع البحر الميت يمتد نعم يمتد في الاردن
وسوريا
والى الى الشمال ليلتقي بصدع شرق الاناضول
هذا الصدع يعني ما بيصير فيه زلازل غير
على فترات متباعده تقريبا تاريخيا كل 500
سنه بيصير زلزال في هذا الصدر
العربيه كامله بعيده عن انشطه الزلازل
لا ما هي بعيده طبعا بيصير في هذه الازال
على زلازل على سبيل المثال صار اخر زلزال
في خليج العقبه عام 95
وبالنسبه الى الزلازل اللي في البحر
الاحمر هذه زلازل غير مخيفه نهائيا ولا
تؤثر على
المدن الساحليه في المملكه لانها لما تكلم
حتى بعد الصدع اللي يشق منتصف البحر
الاحمر
بعيد عرض البحر الاحمر من 200 الى 300
كيلو تلاقي منتصفه عالميه وخمسين كيلو
من الشمال الى الجنوب وكل الزلازل اللي
بتقع فيه زلازل من ضعيفه الى متوسطه
وبيصرنها ايضا تهوين الموجات الزلزاليه
بتعدي على طبقات بيصير لها او تهين الى ان
تصل الى المدن الساحليه على المطل على
البحر الاحمر وهذه ما كانت مؤثره نهائيا
وحتى الزلازل اللي سايره سابقا ما تعدت من
عام 67 او من الس الى الان ما تعدت السته
يعني ما تعدت دكتور هاني يعني يعني هل هل
هل تطمئن سكان
الشرق الاوسط الخليج ايضا تحديدا بانهم
بعيدين تماما عن خطر اي زلازل مشابهه الله
يكفينا يعني نفس
الزلازل اللي حدثت يعني في تركيا في سوريا
لانه في كثير شائعات وكثير حديث عن هذا
الموضوع وانشطه زلزاليه في اكثر من منطقه
في العالم فبالتالي الخوف او الخشيه موجود
وبالنسبه لدول الخليج دول الخليج طبعا
كلها بتقع في بعيده عنها اقرب صدع لها
اللي هو صدع زاجروس وتوروس اللي هو من
ناحيه ايران وهذا ما ياثر على دول الخليج
طبعا تاثيره كل شعور وتاثير ضعيف ما هو
مدمر ولا هو ياسر حتى لو سار زلزال بقوه
سبعه هناك ما ياثر على دول غريب بعيده
كمسافه وايضا ارتداديه
وحتى الهزات الارتداديه بدايه بتكون اضعف
من الزلازل الرئيسيه بتصير ولكن يعني لما
تجي تطالع ايضا حتى اللي هو
على سبيل المثال اللي هو صدع الشرق
الاناضول اللي في في تركيا هذا الصدع هو
عباره عن شمال سوريا وجنوب تركيا يعني جزء
جنوبي من تركيا
الاخيره نعم بالضبط بين الصفيحه العربيه
والصفيحه الصفيحه
وصدع انزلاقي هذا اللي صار فيه زلزال لو
جينا احنا رجعنا للصدع اللي هو شماله شضع
صدع شمال الاناضول على سبيل المثال هذا
الزلازل يعني من عام 39 من عام 1939 وبعد
كذا صار زلزال اللي بعده يليه في المكان
مكانيا وزمانيا عام 42 و43 وفي الخمسينات
وفي 99 كل الزلازل السابقه اللي سايره في
تركيا سايره على شمال الاناضول وكانت
التوقعات كلها انه يصير الزلازل في تركيا
على هذا الصدع وتؤثر على على سبيل المثال
على اسطنبول والمناطق هذه
الدراسات ومتتبعي التاريخ بانه لم يكن
يمكن مفاجاه لكن التوقيت كان مفاجئ والحجم
ايضا كذلك المساحه الجغرافيه شكرا جزيلا
لك من جده رئيس اللجنه الاستشاريه للزلازم
مدير مركز الازمات الكوارث في هيئه
المساحه الجيولوجيه السعوديه الدكتور هاني
زهران شكرا يا دكتور
في السعوديه اطلق مركز البحوث والتواصل
المعرفي اول مدرسه سعوديه لصنع الفكر
لصناعه جيل من المفكرين السعوديين بوصفها
مبادره عمليه لدعم قطاع صناعه الفكر وفق
منهج علمي يتوائم مع متطلبات رؤيه
السعوديه المركز السعودي اطلق ايضا مبادره
دي في المتخصصه في تطوير وتمكين مراكز
الفكر ومؤسسات المجتمع المدني في الشرق
الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
كبار صناع الترفيه والابتكارات العالميه
غدا في المنتدى الدولي للترفيه
مدير وكاله طاقه الذريات يؤكدوا ان ايران
وافقت على استئناف اجراءات المراقبه في
المنشات النوويه
في اول تدريب من نوعه السعوديه وامريكا
تجريان مناورات مشتركه نهايه مارس
لمواجهتها هجمات مسيرات
بعد تكونات بتعرض البحر الاحمر لخطر
الزلزال خبراء جيولوجيون يؤكدون ان دول
الخليج بعيده عن الهزات
في اول نسخ مسابقه المهارات الثقافيه
السعوديه اكثر من 240 الف مشاركه من
المدارس يخوضون رحله من سبع محطات
حياكم الله من جديد باشرت السلطات
السعوديه في مدينه الرياض التحقيق في حاله
تعنيف من قبل اب لبناته عبر الضرب
والاحتجاز السلطات السعوديه اعلنت عن
احاله المتورط الى النيابه العامه كما جرى
تقديم الحمايه للمتضررات بالتنسيق مع مكتب
الحمايه الاسريه السعوديه
سبعه عشره ماده جرم بها النظام السعودي
التعنيف الاسري
وغيرها من الجرائم التي يواجهها نظام
الحمايه من الايذاء النظام يحضر كافه
اعمال العنف ضد المراه جسديا ونفسيا او
حتى التهديد به ويفرض النظام على المتهمين
عقوبات جزائيه منها السجن لمده تصل الى
سنه وغرامه ماليه تصل الى 50 الف ريال
قابله للتغليظ ووضع النظام السعودي مجموعه
من الاهداف لمكافحه التعنيف الاسري ابرزها
ايجاد اليات علميه وتطبيقيه للتعامل مع
الايذاء بالاضافه الى توفير الايواء
ورعايه الاجتماعيه والنفسيه والصحيه
للمتضررين وخصصا نظام السعودي خطه ساخنه
او خطا ساخنا للاستجابه الفوريه لحمايه كل
من يتعرض لاي شكل من اشكال العنف
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو المحامي
اصيل الحسن سيد اصيل حياك الله
اهلا وسهلا فيك يمكن تابعت هذه هذه
الحادثه
لهذا الاب الذي عنف بناته وخليني اسال انت
بحكم انك محامي تمر عليك كثير من هذه
القضايا ما الدافع لمثل هذه الحوادث اولا
اولا نرجع للخط الزمني لهذه المشكله هي
عائده الى ما قبل الاسلام حتى كانوا نجدهم
انهم يمنعون الارث للبنات او للاولاد وادي
البنات من هذه الحادثه هذه احدى حالات
العنف الاسري وهذا ممتد من
وتطورت مع الوقت الى ان اصبحت الان في
نظام السعودي خلصها وحجمها لان النظام
السعودي اصدر فيها نظام عام 1434 فهذه
الحادثه فاصبحت من الحالات النادره وتردنا
احنا كمكاتب محاماه حالات مثل هذه ولكن
قليله نوعا ما لا اخفيك وهي قلتها لسببين
السبب الاول انه المبلغ يخاف والسبب
الثاني لانه النظام كان حازم في هذه
النقطه ولكن في حاله انه شخص اطلع على
حاله عنف يحق له انه يبلغ
ويوجه الجهات الامنيه والجهات الضبط
الاداري المتمثله في الشرطه وفي الامن
الاسري يقدر يبلغ فيهم ولو ثبت انه هذه
الحاله غير صحيحه اذا كان حسن النيه يعفى
من العقوبه اما اذا كان سيء نيه يعاقب
وخليني اسالك اليوم النظام في السعوديه
عندنا 17 ماده جرم فيها النظام السعودي
التعنيف الاسري او ايضا حتى يعني التعنيف
ضد المراه جسديا ونفسيا وحتى لفظيا
بسال انا هنا النظام في السعوديه كيف
يواجه مثل هذه الحوادث طبعا النظام
السعودي واجه هذه الحوادث اول شيء بكل قوه
وحزم وسريه تامه يعني مهمه نقطه السريه
لانه انت بتتكلم في مشكله اسريه انت عارف
ان هناك كمجتمع شرقي يحكمنا العادات
والتقاليد والسمعه تهمنا يعني فهذه كانت
وفقا للنظام النظام صحيح انه 17 ماده لكن
مشتمل على اغلب النقاط تعالج بكل سريه
وحتى المبلغ اذا كان من خارج الاسره او من
داخل الاسره يمنع منعا باتا اظهار اسمه
الا اذا رغب هو وتكون هنالك موافقه خطيه
انه انا لا امانع من اظهار رسمي وكذلك
الجار اذا اطلع على حادثه عنف اسري للجار
اللي جنبه ترى يبلغ وممكن انه يقول حفظ حق
الجار انا اشيل اسمي عشان لا يتعدى هذه
السؤال عن نقطه ايضا حتى مهمه اليوم هل
تلمس فيه وعي لدى المجتمع بخطوره هذه
الحوادث يعني التعنيف الاسري العنف ضد
المراه او حتى التهديد او حتى يعني
لا نقول حتى الاعتداء جسديا حتى الاعتداء
لفظيا
هذه كانت منتشره في الزم في الازمنه
السابقه لكن في الوقت الحالي قد تكون
نادره
بمعنى انه تم تحجيمها بشكل او باخر ولكن
اذا كانت
اذا كانت موجوده فهي موجوده عند بعض
الاشخاص اللي كانوا اساسا مورست عليهم في
تربيتهم كان في عنف وهو تندرج من ضمن
حالات العنف اللي هو مشاهده الاب يضرب
زوجته فبالتالي يتربى الطفل على العنف
فبالتالي الطفل يصبح رجل ويعامل نفس
اولادها مساله مو وراثيه لانه هذه مكتسبه
يكتسب انه لا افهمك الا بطريقه الضرب
ونجد ايضا في بعض الحالات
يندرج من تحت العنف الاسري اللي هو تعنيف
المراه للخادمه يندرج من تحتها العنف
الاسري
فهذه الحاله من حالات العنف الاسري دكتور
خلال السنوات الاخيره اللي صار عندنا فيها
تنظيم اكثر وصرفي وعي اكثر لدى
وصارت الناس تعرف خطورتها الموضوع وفي
انظمه وفي ايضا
غرامات في عقوبات ايضا جزائيه اريد ان
اسال هنا عن
يعني العدد القضايا التي تصلكم مع الوقت
هل قلتها انعدمت بشكل كبير من وقت صدور
القرار او من وقت صدور النظام لا كان فيه
زي ما نقول هجمه
لهذه البلاغات اما في الاونه الاخيره لاما
وردتني ان شخصيا بلاغات بكثره كان سابقا
يريدني شكوى
بمعدل شكوى كل اسبوع الان لا يمكن في
السته شهور الماضيه ما وردتني شيء
هذه من الحالات اللي تكون عندنا كمكتب
محاماه خاص فيني اخيرا خليني اسالك عن
العقوبات اذا سمحت صحيح العقوبات اذا كانت
العقوبه على الشخص السوي العادي
او في المجمل في العام من
شهر الى سنه هو من غرامه من 5000 الى
خمسين الف وتغلظ العقوبه ممكن تكون اكثر
من 50 ممكن تكون اكثر من اي نعم اذا كانت
المراه حامل اذا كان
منمورس عليه العنف هذا اذا كان من ذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه اذا كان من مسلوبي
الاراده اذا كان
ممن يجب عليه رعايتهم وفرط في هذا الواجب
تصل هذه العقوبه من سنه الى خمس سنوات ومن
خمسين الف الى 300 الف ما نضطر لها وانها
تنعدم هذه الحوادث تماما عندنا شكرا جزيلا
لك كان معي هنا في الاستوديو المحامي اصيل
الحسن شكرا سيد قصيد عفوا
اعلنت هيئه الترفيه السعوديه عن استضافه
المنتدى الدولي للترفيه في مدينه الرياض
والذي يجمع كبار صناع الترفيه يستعرض ابرز
الابتكارات العالميه في القطاع لمده يومين
بدا من الغد المنتدى الدولي للترفيه يتضمن
مع رضا لكبرى الشركات المحليه والعالميه
ويقدم ايضا جلسات وورش عمل لتطوير القطاع
الترفيهي
اعلنت وزاره الثقافه السعوديه استقطاب
اكثر من 240 الف مشاركه من المدارس في اول
نسخ مسابقه المهارات الثقافيه التي
اطلقتها الوزاره بالتنسيق مع وزاره
التعليم المسابقه الثقافيه السعوديه تتضمن
سبع محطات بدءا من اكتشاف المبدعين وصولا
الى عمليه تدريبهم من خلال برنامج تفاعلي
شامل لرفع كفاءه المشاركات الابداعيه
وتنافس المشاركين على جوائز تصل الى خمسه
ملايين ريال
تنضم الينا من الرياض قطان وكيله وزاره
الثقافه للشركات الوطنيه والتطويريه
سيد انواع حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه
من الرياض وخلينا نسال اولا يعني 247 الف
هذا عدد كبير في اول نسخه هل كان هذا
المستهدف من البدايه
كمقارنه بالمسابقات الاخرى في نفس هذا
المجال حتى في دول اخرى كان يمكن المستهدف
ما يتراوح بين 20 الى 40 الف مشاركه
واليوم اضعاف هذا المشاركات الحمد لله دعم
القياده بتوجيهاتها اكيد ممتاز نساله ايضا
عن هالمسابقه لماذا هذه المسابقه وايش
المحطات اللي يمر فيها المشاركين ايضا في
هذه المسابقه النتيجه معروفه هي جوائز لكن
ابغى اسال عن البدايه عن هذه المسابقه ليش
موجوده وايش المحطات اللي موجوده في ايضا
كذلك
هذه المسابقه احدى المبادرات
التي الثقافيه اللي نتجت عن الشراكه بين
وزاره التعليم وزاره الثقافه احد محاور
هذه الاستراتيجيه بشكل كبير واكتشاف
المواهب ليس فقط الهدف الجوائز لكن فعلا
اكتشاف هذه المواهب صقلها وتنميتها وصولها
الى مستوى محترف او مستوى متطور
فهذا يمكن بدايه المسابقه وفكرتها وكانت
ايضا فكره ان احنا نكتشف الميدان بدخول
هذه المجالات الثقافيه الجديده على
التعليم يمكن ما كانت موجوده سابقا فاليوم
عندنا سته محاور مختلفه في المسابقه ضمنها
التراث المسرح الموسيقى الادب الافلام
الفنون البصريه
ما هي كلها موجوده ضمن مناهج التعليميه او
يومنا التعليم
في برنامج تفاعلي ايضا موجود في هذه
في هذه المسابقه والفعاليه التي تنظمونها
بالتعاون مع وزاره التعليم اللي هو
البرنامج التفاعلي وشو ممكن نعرف عنها
البرنامج
الفكره بالفعل
يمكن المحطات او عدد من محطات اللي موجوده
ضمن المسابقه واحدا هي بعد اكتشاف المرحله
الاولى وفرز المشاركات البدء بعمل دورات
تدريبيه مختلفه للمسارات حقه
وهذه تسمح لنا لان احنا ناخذ هذه المهارات
ولو بشكل مبدئي ونبدا نطورها لمشاركه
جديده نبدا نصفي فيها التصفيه الاولى
لمشاركات اكثر احترافيه
ففكره التدريب في عدد من الخبراء
والمختصين اللي نتعاون معاهم بكل مجال من
مجالات
ونبدا يعني تعتبر جزء منها اكتشاف هذه
المواهب وجزء منها تنميتها او التدريب
بشكل اكبر عليها
طيب انت ذكرتي المجالات اللي يركز عليها
او تركز على هذه المسابقه يعني مجالات
كلها مختصه في مجالات يعني ثقافيه او
موسيقيه وفيها فنون ايضا كذلك لكن خليني
اسال بعد مرحله الفرز ومرحله ايضا حتى
حصول المتسابقين فيها على الجوائز
المشاركين من هذه الوزاره هل ستدخلونهم في
برامج ممكن يكون مستقبل في برامج ابتعاث
لهم او تنميه هذه المهارات
بالفعل ماليه واللي تصل قيمتها كمجموعه
يمكن اكثر من خمسه مليون ريال لكل
المسابقه والمشاركين فيها وفي
مجال الجوائز العينيه جوائز العينيه تختلف
اما من اجهزه او هالات او نوع من التدريب
اللي ممكن يحصل عليه الفائز لتنميه هذا
المهاره او حتى الدخول في مجال الابتعاد
او
تبني لهذه المواهب واستمراريتها مع
الوزاره بدعم مستمر عليها اشكرك جزيل
الشكر بالتوفيق لكم ان شاء الله من الرياض
قطان وكيله وزاره الثقافه للشركات الوطنيه
والتطوير شكرا جزيلا لك
قسم العرب السنين لقسمين سنين مجدبه وسنين
غصبه التفاصيل في التقويم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تنقسم السنين الى قسمين سنين مجدبه وسنين
خصبه الخصبه معناها ربيع وفقع وعراجيل
وجراد هالمطر يطلع لنا الربيع وتتابعه
يطلع لنا الفقع والعراجين وانتشار الربيع
يجلب لنا الجراد ولقط الفقع والعراجيل
ومطارده الجراد من الفراسه ومن الرياضات
المحببه لنا والفقع والعراجين فطر
والاكثار منه مضر والجراد يقولون انه نافع
ولذيذ ولهذا العام يقولون لو طلع الفجر
والكراد له مراحل ادبه وهو صغير اللي يمشي
على الارض وياكل الاخضر واليابس ومنه سنه
الدبا والغوغاء وهو الجراد المتوسط اللي
طالعين له جنحان لكنه مع باع الطار وله
صوت هذا صوت ما يخليه يطير والجراده هي
التي تطير ولها جنحان وتنقسم الى قسمين
الذكر لونه اسود ويسميها العامه بالزعيري
والانثى ولونه اصفر ويسميها العامه بالمكن
والجراد ينقسم الى قسمين جرادهم مستوطن
وجراد مهاجر المهاجر يجينا من السودان ومن
اريتريا ومن الحبشه ففي موسم الخريف يهاجر
على رجليه الى ساحل البحر الاحمر ولا منه
طلع له جنحان وكبر يجي لنا على شكل سحب خش
عن ابصارهم يخرجون من الاجداث كانهم جراد
منتشر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
ختام الرابع بابرز عناوينها
مدير وكاله الطاقه الذريه يؤكد ان ايران
وافقت على استئناف اجراءات المراقبه في
المنشات النوويه
في اول تدريب من نوعها السعوديه وامريكا
تجريان مناورات مشتركه نهايه مارس
لمواجهتها هجمات المسيرات
بعد تكهنات بتعرض البحر الاحمر لخطر
الزلزال خبراء جيولوجيون يؤكدون ان دول
الخليج بعيده عن الهزات
في اول نسخ مسابقه مهارات الثقافيه
السعوديه اكثر من 240 الف مشاركه من
المدارس يقضون رحله من سبع محطات
شكرا لكم لكرامل متابعه نهايه الرابعه الى
اللقاء